then you think you come from a long line
of Irish dancers for you and what age
were you when you started dancing I was
11 Olivia I know what does this
frustrate you that people often do Carmo
keaur Irish dancing you know I don't
judge anyone let everybody do what they
want it's all good
because sometimes people just pretending
to arch dance does look very like Irish
dancing
it can yeah you you're not wrong there
we're not so an experiment and if we
take some people um hang on it's not
very good look at me do it you've got
sick no the man in the t-shirt the man
in the t-shirt
no you're warm Sam Leah Liam actually
what's your name the keys are you Irish
yeah oh this is perfect
what's in case yeah okay so you'll be
good at this
did you learn it in school apparently I
did it better be fantastic okay come
down here come down here okay so if they
strike what should it like sort of a
like that if they do that you're doing
good okay so this rustic opening solo
cheese very good look leg across and
everything Oh Oh Tom's in yeah okay so
okay so you ready okay we just got a
little bit a little blast of Irish
dancing oh wait wait wait we're here
it's mean look let's get more people if
some of you come out if all of you come
out all of you come out okay stand up
come you step down step down everyone
step down okay there you go
and if you put your right foot out like
that
okay good at Liam and what's your name
Emer case the Inman case okay everyone
ready take it away
No
Julianne Moore has an Oscar risk but you
don't know sorry to bring you down it's
because when people go on holiday
they're just like I deserve to not clean
my own crap out of my turbo